for a movie about dolls made out of
plastic Barbie shows an unexpected heart
and Humanity if you were thrown by the
big themes in this story about toys
don't worry we've got you warning
spoilers for Barbie ahead Barbie begins
with Margot Robbie's Barbie in Barbie
land the Fantastical pastel colored
feminist Utopia and home to every Barbie
who has ever lived there's also Issa
Ray's president Barbie Hari neff's Dr
Barbie Alexandra ship's author Barbie
and so many others there are Ken's too
they're all named Ken including Ryan
Gosling's Ken every day Barbie has the
best day of her life while Ken just
hopes Barbie will look his way in Barbie
land Barbies are just being Barbie
building one another up with praise and
support and love while Ken's Pine on the
outskirts trying to outshine one another
in the hopes of getting some attention
or respect it's a never-ending cycle but
one day Robbie Barbie's idyllic little
routine begins to crumble with strange
unfamiliar symptoms Barbie discovers the
issues she's facing including cellulite
and pervasive thoughts of death do you
guys ever think about dying
are the result of the tether between
Barbie land and the real world basically
the Barbies in Barbie land are tied to
the humans who play with them in the
real world whatever child is playing
with this particular Barbie is
struggling with more complex issues and
they're poisoning her otherwise perfect
existence the only way for her to
restore herself to factory settings is
to physically go into the real world a
place that the residents of Barbie land
have some major misconceptions about
once she traverses the theoretical
Wormhole between the two Realms with her
stowaway Cannon toe Barbie is
immediately struck by the power
structure in the real world simply put
men rule the world here and women do not
a paradigm shift that perturbs Barbie
but intrigues Ken if that culture shock
wasn't enough when she finally finds
Sasha the young girl Barbie saw in her
Visions as the disaffected child causing
her issues she is stunned to discover
that she and her gen Z friends hate
Barbie She's shaken by the passionate
damning indictment they inflict upon her
noting Barbie's toxic cultural footprint
crass consumerism and noxious effect on
beauty standards and by extension
women's mental Wellness over half a
century at her lowest point Barbie is
kidnapped by Mattel agents at the order
of their CEO everyone at Mattel just
wants Barbie to get back in a box and
teleport back home Ken isn't something
we're worried about but soon her and
Ken's presence has the same effect on
the real world Sasha's cynicism has had
on Barbie or be fleas and is saved by
Sasha's mother Gloria a Mattel employee
who is revealed to be the real cause of
Barbie's plight she had been playing
with her and her daughter's old dolls in
an attempt to reconnect with her grouchy
disaffected child Barbie convinces them
to join her back in Barbie land hoping
the Paisley Majesty of her home will
inspire Sasha to be less jaded and to
stop hating Barbie as a cultural icon
perhaps it'll help repair Sasha and
Gloria's relationship in the process and
at least on a smaller scale fulfill some
of the destiny Barbie had thought
already was cemented before her
unfortunate sojourn to the real world
when they actually make it back to
Barbie land they discover it is not what
it once was it is now kandom Robbie's
Barbie has no real allies among the
dolls and doesn't feel special enough to
enact change with President Barbie and
the others having given into being
Housewives so our Barbie lays down and
gives up to escape the Macho Madness
that Barbie land has become Gloria Sasha
and Barbie Hyde at weird Barbies
compound Gloria gives Barbie a dramatic
and heartfelt speech about the inherent
difficulty of being a woman and it snaps
Barbie out of her doldrums the gang
deprograms author Barbie and puts
together an elaborate plan to do the
same to the other Barbies One By One The
liberated Barbies will distract the cans
while Gloria gives the other Barbies the
talk that brings them back to their
senses step two of this plan is to
systematically deflate the Ken's Egos
and set them against one another
continuing to hide in plain sight under
the guise of obedient Housewives until
the right time to strike Gosling's Ken
is hurt by the side of his Barbie
flirting with his archrival simulyu's
Ken leading the Kens to go to literal
war with each other the initial violence
and brutality don't last for very long
though Ken's solo song I'm Ken seems to
strike a chord within all the other Kens
as their dance fighting becomes
something more collaborative in spite of
themselves they've stumbled upon the
solidarity and brotherly love their
short-sighted existences had been
missing out on this entire time the war
now over Barbie land reverts to normal
with some added concession for the cans
when Barbie first gets to the real world
she's horrified to discover its
patriarchal structure Ken however isn't
scared of it he's elated after getting a
bunch of library books about the
patriarchy from the library he fails to
get an important job for the simple
reason he is a man but I'm a man but not
a doctor can I talk to a doctor you are
talking to a doctor Ken thus decides
that the real world is doing patriarchy
wrong and he needs to take those ideas
somewhere new to fully realize them so
he functionally takes over Barbie land
teaching all the other Kens to subjugate
their respective Barbies they turn the
dream houses into man caves the
choreographed disco parties become
acoustic guitar covers of Matchbox
twenties push the Ken's convince every
Barbie to stop being a girl boss and
just pass her boy abruski the Ken's
throw out the Constitution and corrupt
everything Barbie land once was much to
Barbie's Chagrin when she returns with
Gloria and Sasha once the Barbies
distract the Kens to reinstate their
constitution and return Barbie land to
its former Splendor Ken still doesn't
know who he is or or where he belongs he
realizes he lost his enthusiasm for
patriarchy when he discovered it didn't
involve horses to the degree he once
imagined Barbie apologizes for the way
she treated Ken but has to caution him
that this isn't a happy romantic ending
for the two of them she says he needs to
spend time and energy defining his own
place in this world outside of trying to
court her president Barbie agrees to
give the Kens more representation in
their government meanwhile the Mattel
execs who crossed the beach portal are
satisfied agreeing to start producing
Gloria's idea for an everyday Barbie
everyone gets some kind of conclusion
they find satisfying that is except for
Robbie's Barbie she wonders aloud if
there's anything left for her to do
still feeling confused and bothered by
all she's experienced she still sees
herself as too ordinary and
unexceptional to deserve the kind of
happy ending a movie like this is
supposed to have but that's when Ruth
Handler the creator of Barbie played by
Rhea Perlman appears she's essentially
God in Barbie land and she offers Barbie
some holy counsel Handler talks to
Barbie about the true nature of life and
death along with what it means to be a
human moved by all this Barbie asks if
she can be a human too but after all
she's endured on this quirky Adventure
she finds she already is in the film's
final moments Barbie goes with Gloria
and her family to some important event
with the tenor of the scene suggesting
this will be her first day at her first
human job perhaps a gig working at
Mattel as a creative her earlier
monologue implied that could be on the
horizon but for the film's final joke
her destination is revealed to be a
gynecologist's office here I go
at numerous points in the film
characters including Mattel's CEO weird
Barbie and Ruth the Creator offer up
crucial pieces of lore Laden with the
burning necessity for follow-up
questions only to hand wave them away so
when the film concludes with Barbie
turning from a doll to a real human
being Ruth's phrasing implies that this
last climactic moment wasn't Alchemy but
rather the Final Act of a transformative
character Arc Barbie goes from being a
one-dimensional and idealized toy whose
world has never known struggle
contradiction or the finality that
defines a human life to becoming a
thinking and feeling entity who endures
the full spectrum of existence all in a
single day by pulling Barbie out of the
fictional and aspirational artifice she
was born into and placing her within our
very real world and all its
complications she ascends from dollhood
to Womanhood bearing the massive weight
her gender must shoulder to Simply exist
it's easier to believe Barbie became
Human by virtue of magical
transformation like Pinocchio and that's
a valid reading of what happens but it's
also clear that a more pragmatic
explanation is just as valid just like
the true nature of Barbie's final
evolution the uneasy relationship
between Barbie land and the real world
is interesting to ponder we're told
initially that what happens to the dolls
in Barbie land is the direct result of
what the kids in the real world do
during play time so why then is Mattel
so afraid of a doll in the real world
and why does that give Barbie land
similar power over reality before Barbie
is a physical play thing in the real
world she is an idea a big one housed
within a malleable plastic totem when
Sasha lashes out at Barbie all the
particulars of her scathing rant outline
the many ways that Barbie the doll
shapes reality the doll has become an
ideal that on some level Flesh and Blood
women must be compared to how can you
compete with an object designed to be
perfect when you're a human being who is
by nature imperfect we shape pop culture
but we imbue art and products with the
power to shape us too so of course the
figures scrubbed clean of all our
ungainly Humanity bounce right back at
us reshaping the world as we know it in
ways surprising and previously
unimaginable it's also why the ideas Ken
brings back from The Real World wreaks
so much havoc on Barbie land Barbie
land's idyllic Paradise is informed
entirely by a fragile barricade of lofty
tenants utterly undone the moment they
come into contact with contradictory
Concepts from the broken world that
initially birthed them Barbie
miraculously is able to expand upon the
reflexive nature of the dream and the
dreamer neither knowing who is truly
asleep ideas live forever given director
Greta gerwig's unbridled enthusiasm for
the brand and the film's commercial
success thus far sequels to Barbie are
more a question of when rather than if
there are plenty of Barbies and Ken's to
follow into their own similarly
metadromedy vehicles that evolve from
the blueprint set out in the first film
too many talented young actors appear
here for one of them to not get another
shot as their respective doll identities
but with Mattel pledging to exploit all
the other toys in their massive IP toy
box there may be a larger Mattel
Cinematic Universe that Barbie would
merely be a player in how exactly could
Barbie team up with He-Man or the cars
from Hot Wheels or Rock'em sock'em
robots if you've made it this far and
have already seen Barbie you know that
the doors are blown wide open for any
manner of tie-in to make some kind of
emotional sense even if it's found to be
wanting in the logic Department Barbie
could end up in Eternia and the right
combination of winking nodding and
sharply employed 80s or 90s needle drops
on the soundtrack truck will smooth over
any rockiness between the various Brands
respective identities
reviews of Barbie have called it movie
of the summer as well as one of the best
of the Year highlighting Gerwig and
co-writer Noah Bombeck script as well as
her Direction but where will things go
next Robbie told time it could go a
million different directions from this
point Gerwig expressed enthusiasm about
a potential Barbie franchise in an
interview with variety but there are no
solid plans whether or not Gerwig
herself will return to the director's
chair is a more difficult call given the
rumors around her and the Narnia
Universe over at Netflix but a more
tantalizing question is whether the
Barbie verse will cross over with
another toy birthed franchise this
summer we've already seen that Hasbro
and Paramount's twin toy juggernauts GI
Joe and Transformers are joining forces
and we know Mattel and Hasbro are buddy
buddy enough when it comes to mutually
beneficial licensing opportunities
they're even planning a Barbie Monopoly
game who's to say the real world Barbie
has entered isn't the same one with
robots that turn into cars and stealth
ninjas working with independent military
contractors to fight terrorism
I'm
confused about that
foreign